julian bats from d.c
hi crew how are you julian how old are
you
i'm 25. okay because i know you're the
youngest person to compete in college
week is that correct
yeah i was 18. okay you wrote freshman
at the time
you got three answers wrong
that were crucial yes that is all right
three answers the trifecta the internet
calls you
uh the world's worst uh
wheel of fortune player i saw that i saw
that and that just crushed me because i
as an 18 year old you're already going
through so much
you're already like experiencing college
for the first time there's so many
different things and then you have
that wow it's it's a lot it's a lot to
balance
i really understand how did you feel
having that happen in front of other
people i'm curious because i've had that
too but
what was your lesson or how did you
process it
that's a great question i think you know
when i was on wheel
that was such a a whirlwind experience
to be there
you are in la on the set
you have the wheel you have everything
around you
that you've watched on tv for so many
years
quite frankly like i was in such awe
right after it happened like once
everything was taped everything was done
i went back to my hotel and i just sat
there and said what
just happened no words no
i have to say the world's fastest car i
would have thought the same thing too
yes it's true when you're like lights on
spotlight
freak out live tv like so true
and with and with that puzzle in
particular i
had picked up like a car so like i was
i was like two letters away from solving
that puzzle
and i did not have a moment to just just
like
you know like we need a moment to just
breathe and you sing just like take in
the moment
and just collect yourself i needed like
10 of those
that day well you know what let's do a
drew over
all right okay i'm ready i am so ready
okay so it's game show week on the show
and i grew up watching game shows and i
just i love them
and um they're so positive but
they can be life-altering apparently and
we're gonna give
uh you the chance to win a prize
okay is that cool julian that sounds
cool with me i'm ready
okay it's time to play julian's second
chance in 60 seconds
okay julian a phrase is going to come up
on the screen with missing letters
and you're going to have 60 seconds to
guess
the missing letter you're going to say a
letter and then we're going to fill the
screen
and if you can't get it guess the next
letter okay that sounds good
i'm ready so on and so on in 60 seconds
okay let's go and if you get it then you
win something
okay that's so exciting i'm ready to go
i'm ready okay
julian i'm rooting for you are you ready
let's go
all right go let's look at the puzzle
all right julian what's your first
letter my first letter
is an e it's already on the focus my
next letter is a y yes give me a y
okay next letter the next letter is an o
yes give me an o hurry
my next letter is a c next letter is a c
go my next letter is an l
give me an l i'm ready i'm ready
i'm going to solve i want to solve i
want to solve okay go
i'm going to go full hero achilles
oh gosh i'm not kidding i got sick to my
stomach i'm
so nervous i had to make sure
that you kind of felt that energy that i
did that day
so there you go you're welcome i
understand
it's physical i know i know
it's it's unimaginable so much harder
do you want to know what you won what do
i win
it's a brand new 2021 hyundai
accent
[Applause]
thank you so much oh my gosh that is
so i speechless
that is amazing thank you so much
julian i i really uh
relate to your story i do i've had to
figure out plenty of things
in front of everybody and it's how every
person feels in a high school
or an inner office job situation or in a
small town
and these feelings are necessary in life
they're unavoidable and they're totally
just relative and relatable for all
and i i thank you for having such a good
spirit about it
thank you it has been such an honor to
meet you
and i just think that is such good
energy to bring
at the end of the day we're all human we
are all
on this earth and we make mistakes we
make mistakes but at the end of the day
we can laugh about it we can smile
we can move on to better things and i am
so grateful for this opportunity so
thank you again
thank you julian and i just really want
to send
a very big special heaps of gratitude to
hyundai
of south brunswick because they are who
made this dream possible
so thank you and thank you julian